good morning believe nation today's
message is believe in yourself over to
you Tyrese Gibson I love me so the day
that you decide to stop loving me I'm
not gonna love myself any less I believe
in me if you stop believing in me I'm
not gonna believe in myself any less if
you believe that I'm irrelevant that no
one is checking for me and that I don't
mean anything to the world because you
think or believe that about me
it doesn't believe it doesn't mean that
I'm gonna believe it about myself see
the day that you start living your life
according to everybody else's opinion is
the beginning of the end most of y'all I
see it every day all day most of you
guys don't actually know your self-worth
you don't know your self value so you're
like a vulnerable little child and
you're shaking and it's like everybody
loves me this week so I love me this
week next week it drops so now you're
running around and secure feeling
self-conscious and not loving yourself
sad and depressed
based on the feedback the response is
and the energy that the rest of the
world is giving you I wrote about this
in my new book which is coming it's
called black rose it hasn't been
released yet but it's coming I talked
about the fact that Fame is an addiction
fame is one of the most unspoken
addictions out there so many celebrities
and entertainers athletes and public
figures they base their self-worth
on their relevancy based on everybody in
the world checking form and as soon as
people stop checking for
then they stop checking for they self
y'all don't love me no more I'm not
selling records I'm not number one in
the box office no more I'm not making as
much money as I used to make oh ain't
nobody checking for me so guess what I'm
not checking for myself no one sees the
value in me anymore so I don't see the
value in me anymore every time I go on
Twitter Facebook they say I'm irrelevant
so I'm irrelevant to myself now I ain't
because you think that I ain't [ __ ] no
one loves me because you said no one
loves me I don't love me the day that
you allow the opinions of the outside
world to dictate the way you feel about
yourself it is the beginning of the end
of you living a blessed and self loving
secure life I can tell y'all right now
that it is not the car that I Drive or
any de jure that I own or the size of my
house that defines my self-worth I'm hot
I'm hot I'm hot when you don't think I'm
hot I'm amazing when you don't think I'm
amazing
I love me even if you stop loving me
you can say the nastiest meanest evilish
that you could have a conjure up it will
never change the way I feel about myself
I'm telling you that's the way I live my
life that's how I feel about me most of
y'all are on Twitter you're desperate
for likes you're desperate for the the
egotistical feeding frenzy feed my ego
Fifi feed like me like me because I
don't like me
I'm telling y'all right now the day that
you allow the opinions of everybody on
the outside world to define your day to
day month to month and year to year it's
the beginning of the end
love yourself believe in yourself
love yourself believe in yourself
independent of the validation of the
world have opinions and feelings about
yourself independent of the feedback why
you got to have somebody calling you
beautiful everyday in order for you to
feel beautiful do you believe that
you're beautiful or do you only believe
you're beautiful when other people say
that you're beautiful
I'm just asking self-love is the cure to
self hate if you make it to the end of
this video I want you to write self-love
is the cure to self hate these are the
type of qualities that I'm going and
have been in stealing in my daughter
there is no man that you could ever meet
Shayla that can make you feel more
amazing than what you're supposed to
feel about yourself nobody wants to be
alone but if you show up empty as an
empty shell and you're expecting this
man to fulfill you and fill you up with
all of the love that doesn't exist you
gonna be [ __ ] up because as soon as he
leaves you depleted you're empty and you
have nothing left for yourself again
never rely or depend on anybody to
fulfill your heart and if you don't
believe in the Lord Jesus Christ you
better get to know him because that's
also a part of the process of self-love
you are supposed to love yourself
independent of any feedback comments
likes shares in any of all of these
other social media did some of y'all are
social media [ __ ] what does that mean
I I I ain't [ __ ] until people on my
timeline tell me that I'm the [ __ ] I
love me independent of anything that
anybody could ever say has nothing to do
with being arrogant egotistical it's
just a matter of knowing and being aware
of self-worth I love you if you make it
to the end of this video I want you to
write self-love is the cure to self hate
self-love is to cure to self hate and I
hope you share this video because I want
this video to spread all over the world
send it to WorldStarHipHop send it to
all of the blogs and the websites
self-love is the cure
self-hate she-man tyrese spread and love
always share share share click that
share button spread love